foreign
[Music]
good morning everyone and welcome I hope
you all are very well caffeinated we
have a bunch of exciting content for you
in this session
so let's start with introductions first
my name is Avanti Sani and I'm a product
manager in the Google Cloud AI group and
I have with me two amazing guest
speakers today who represent some very
cool Industries and they will be talking
about how they are using our image and
video gen AI capabilities to power their
businesses
so let's spend a moment chatting briefly
about why image and video content is
more powerful than textual content and
the answer is very simple it's because
80 of human Learning Happens visually
and 65 percent of us are primarily
visual learners
in fact the human brain takes about 13
milliseconds to process an image which
is about 60 000 times faster than text
and this is validated by what we see in
the world today right look at the sheer
number of images and videos on the
internet so here are some fun facts uh
video has a 92 percent reach for the
worldwide audience and 3.2 billion
images are shared almost daily
and U.S Enterprises feel this effect
right whether it's in how you're
communicating with your employees or the
impact it's having on your customers
so at Google Cloud we understand this
and we started exploring how image and
video generation capabilities could help
be a game changer for your business
so keeping that in mind the first
product we recently announced was
imagine on vertex AI this is our
Enterprise class image generation and
understanding solution
for this session we will be focusing
more on the uh understanding
understanding part which is basically
two features image captioning and image
q a
let's start with image or visual
captioning so what does it do it's very
simple you give it an image and it
creates a text caption for it
so on the right there's a really good
example for retailers or e-commerce so
let's say today for retail or e-commerce
one of the biggest challenges is having
accurate product descriptions they have
millions of products they have to deal
with and typically they have very less
information to work with so usually it
is some small description a human
hurriedly typed up or they'll have maybe
a pack of photos a product ID and maybe
like a very small description so with
this using an API and you know and you
need no prior knowledge of AIML or
models or fine-tuning or any of that
it's a simple API call you could very
quickly build out a very rich product
catalog
there are some other use cases also
captioning can help it so one of course
is social uh when you look there's a lot
of images that go out in your social
media marketing and you may want
captions for it which you can use to
drive hashtags for example you can also
use it for any kind of Auto tagging or
categorization now that you know what
the image is actually about and then of
course accessibility it makes it more
accessible for all human beings
so let's look at a demo these are the
two images I will be using in the demo
and just by the way they were created on
imagine
thank you
all right
so if you go to a generative Studio you
should have a capsule you should have a
tab called caption and you can go there
and you can upload an image now this
image does not have to be generated
specifically by imagine it could be any
image you have
on the right we have some parameters so
you can choose the number of captions
and you can you have a choice of five
languages
so let go let's go ahead and generate
the caption
there you go pretty accurate huh
let's try another image and let's try
different parameters this time
so let's go for the sushi one I showed
earlier
let's choose three captions and let's go
with French
so the latency should be about 20 to 30
seconds
and there you go anybody who speaks and
reads French and can confirm I did
confirm with the French colleagues so I
think we're good
so that was image captioning for you
let's move on to image q a
so this is again very simple you can
upload any image again it does not have
to be generated by us and you can ask a
question about the image
so for example on the right uh you could
use this let's say if you were the
government and you wanted to make a
tourism app for disabled folks this
would be a great way uh in which they
could navigate people processes objects
ask questions about it and make their
way
now when it comes to visual q a there
are some other great use cases for it so
number one if you have any in-store
experiences so you may have kiosks and
touch screens you may want uh your
customers to be able to interact with
your products better and even if you
don't have in-store experiences you may
want to be able to enable that on your
digital websites
so great way to capture q a impact
so let's look at this demo again so the
sample image is on the right
again in a generative AI Studio you have
a tab called visual q a where you can go
and upload an image
so let's start by asking a question
again you have parameters like number of
captions and right now we only support
English for this feature but we will
have multiple support multiple language
support coming soon
so let's start with a question where we
try to see whether it generally knows
what's happening in this image
yeah it got right there is recording
going on now let's see how well it does
with Counting
right there you go now let's see if we
ask a specific question of about an
object in the image so let's ask them
what the man is wearing
and got that right now let me ask a
higher level semantic question like say
hey what's the vibe in the room for
example
casual so it is kind of getting a
feeling of the image and is able to
answer that very well
so that was visual q a now let's move on
to video description so the two features
I talked about are more on the uh image
now this will be about video so video
description vertex AI is a feature with
which customers can get semantic
understanding of a video
uh in the form of text
now the thing to remember is this is not
video summarization where you start to
lose information for longer videos
and this is not speech to text or closed
captioning where the model focuses on
listening to the video to make sense of
it in video description the model is
seeing what's happening in the video to
make sense of it now this will become
clearer in some of the examples I have
so let's take an example on the right so
today when you go to any video platform
right when you type in a search like in
this case a car chase typically the
videos that come up will either have car
chase in the title or in the movie
description
but with video description now it will
also show videos which don't have that
term in the title or the description but
may actually have a scene of a car chase
in it so this is very powerful from a
relevancy perspective it does two things
so as an end user when you search it
creates more meaningful content and
meaningful searches for you and from a
platform Builder perspective now you can
kind of cross-sell more of your video
content and surface more and more of it
so it's a win-win
there are some other great use cases
video description helps unlock so one of
them is of course metadata now that you
have such detailed information about the
video of course you have richer metadata
which you can use to power you know
better recommendation engines or
searches
another one is automated captions
similar to the one we saw earlier with
images so if you have short form videos
like 15 seconds 30 seconds you can
caption those
accessibility you saw the tourism app
example earlier
and the next one is understanding and
searching important moments so this is a
really cool one so for an entire video
if you had this detailed rendering in
the form of text now you could do
something with it so now that I have the
text format I could search for important
terms in it so for example let's imagine
we have a 6r baseball game video right
and we have its rendering now I could
search for terms like home run strike
audience steering and then it once I
have those moments I can stitch them
together into say a highlight reel so
you see how that really helps you
understand your information and even
change it into different formats
another great one of course would be um
alerts or workflow based actions so for
example let's take a surveillance video
you could set up alerts saying hey
anytime a word the word knife shows up
or gun shows up or people running shows
up you can inform the local police
authorities so this is a very powerful
way in which you can connect it to some
other action
then there's a better ad placement of
course now that you know what the video
is about you can insert more relevant
ads so if I have a video of baking
cookies I can insert an ad for milk
the next one is driving deeper video
analytics this is a super cool one so
typically anybody any organization who
deals with videos and has a large amount
of videos is always very curious to
track how those videos are being used by
users so for example let's take drop off
point which typically most customers
will measure so today when you do a
drop-off Point all you understand is the
user stopped watching the video at let's
say one minute and 29 seconds
but what if now you could cross
reference that with what was happening
at one minute 29 seconds now you've got
an insight about what the user likes or
does not like and this can drive
powerful personalization
and then finally some of you might be
sitting on reels and reels of Legacy
video content and with no understanding
of how you're going to figure it out
right so with video description you
could catalog it which could lead you to
I don't know discover golden nuggets
from the past or repurpose your content
so as you can see there's a whole lot of
value we can get from video descriptions
let's see a quick demo again
so similarly same studio now we have a
tab called video description you go
ahead and select your video
again for the two minute video it's
about 20 to 30 seconds latency
and there you go for every 15 second
chunk it gives you a description
and in the UI experience you can
actually click on the timestamp and go
to that portion of the video so you can
get you understand the relevancy and you
maintain context
you can save this as a Json file and by
the way all the three features I talked
about today all have API support right
out of the box
okay so oops
so that was the demo so we talked about
three features here and I talked about
different use cases for all of them and
you could you see how beneficial those
could be but honestly their true power
really comes together when you use them
in partnership with each other so I have
a hypothetical case study here uh
through which I would like to demo that
so let's suppose we we are a real estate
company called symbol
right and you know as in any industry we
are trying to stay relevant with the
times we try to stay updated we try to
stay relevant to our customers
however like any industry we struggle
with some headwinds so let's pick three
here
so one of the biggest pain points in
real estate is lack of inventory now of
course this could be because there's
just not enough homes on the market but
it could also be because you're just not
fast enough in creating listings which
is a pretty detailed process you'll keep
to sit down and think about it and
create that
the second one is long buying Cycles
obviously people are spending huge
amounts of money when it comes to real
estate so they want to be very careful
they do a lot of due diligence and so
what that means for you is longer lead
times and maybe low conversion rates
the third one is stiff competition so
for our buyers and sellers now there are
newer models of transacting property and
so there's always new businesses popping
up how do you create Revenue with all of
this going on
so let's see how a combination of the
features I discussed earlier can help
with some of these
so first one lack of inventory what if
we provided a capability for our real
estate agents where either using a
mobile experience or a website
experience all they had to do was take
pictures and video of a house and then
it auto creates a listing for it which
includes a beautiful description and it
also extracts information so like things
like hey hardwood floors pool HVAC what
have you because that's what being used
by your end users when they search for
houses and it creates all of that in
absolute seconds
the good thing is as an API developer it
will be easy for them to set this up
that's one and then it also from an end
user perspective so the buyers or the
renters when they are searching they can
do more open-ended searches like today
when you go to any real estate site and
try to narrow down your search it's like
a lot of selecting a lot of filters
right but here I could maybe even put in
a search saying hey show me a house
which has hardwood floors in the living
room and carpet everywhere else and a
pool in the back here so it creates a
customer Delight experience just because
you have that much knowledge about your
content
let's look at the next challenge long
buying Cycles
so like I mentioned earlier typically
that's because most people want to do a
lot of due diligence which means they
will make multiple visits to the
property check it out again and again
and that is what creates the longest
lead time
what if you could provide this
information maybe in a website or a
mobile app where they could ask
questions on their own time as required
um and so that will reduce the time they
spend on evaluating it you can also flip
this feature along so now that you have
this information you could use it for
sellers when they list their house you
say hey we notice there's mold in this
part or there are some tiles missing on
the roof so they can get ahead of it and
do those improvements before they run it
into it during the buying cycle so again
shaving of valuable moments of time from
the from the lead time
and then of course more inclusivity
that's always a plus
third one so stiff competition so we
probably cannot stop other businesses
popping up but what we could do is we
could create either product
differentiation or even launch new
streams of Revenue
so in this example one way we could do
that is because we have all of this
information about the house and its
condition and its state and so to help
that drive the value of the house we
could provide e-appraisal services for
example
some other use cases we could use this
is for uh with the Q a chatbot I showed
earlier maybe now you have online agents
who are available all the time to answer
your questions you know whenever the
user wants it to and then finally you
have information about your customers
what they want you have information
about the houses with images and videos
you could create personalized brochures
so that creates product differentiation
and again customer delay
so
to summarize using the three features I
described above which were image
captioning image q a and video
description and especially using them
together you can save immense time and
effort in understanding the content you
already have that's one once you know
you have that information it will help
you get deeper understanding and insight
of not only the content but also how
your customers are interacting with them
and then number three all of this
together you could create new Revenue
generation streams or create product
differentiation
so with that it comes to I come to the
end of my part of the session we've
talked a lot about hypotheticals but I
think we should talk more about real
life customers are using this in their
businesses and with that I'd like to
hand over to Tomaso who will share a
little bit about how they are using
these features to drive more
personalization
go ahead
awesome thank you Avanti thanks for the
beautiful information that you shared
with us about vertex AI image
description of your description so I'm
Thomas I'm the general manager and
co-founder of connected storage and
today guys I want to walk you through a
real real life Enterprise use case of
how we use image description and video
description within our platform uh what
is our platform uh connected stories
essentially sold for building
personalizing uh
um optimizing optimizing advertising
creative at scale by combining the power
of creative regenerative AI to
essentially remove the complexity and
therefore democratizing access to the
driven created so why personalizing
creative is important essentially media
marketers have only focused on
optimizing targets that'll be watching
inventory whereas the majority of
success of a campaign actually runs
through and is derived by the
effectiveness of that creative so
therefore coming up with effective
creative is key in order to have a
successful marketing and advertising
campaigns however in order to do so
personalization and continuous
optimizations are actually key elements
in order to enable that sort of
effectiveness
but in order to fully harness the power
personalization and uh being able to
continuously optimize such creative
understanding and measuring creative
become key ingredients to success so
that's why when we launch connected
stories since day one we wanted to
utilize AI across all the different tree
models that you see up here on the
platform so the one on the left is
actually our creative Studio which is
generative AI powered it's a
multi-tenant solution that allows
content to be brought to life through
the use of a canvas like interface for
Content creators to mix
um content that are generated by
majority of AI through the integration
of palm and image and within the
platform as well as interactive widgets
to which we can give data-driven
conditions on and therefore applying
them in real time which is then
orchestrated by by our AI based
decisioning system the users Uh custom
machine learning models that are trained
with our own data real-time signals as
well as first part of the clients and
these essentially acts as the
orchestrator that selects the different
variations so that jgi power Studio
comes up with
and finally everything is then measured
in terms of Effectiveness through our
creative intelligence dashboards they're
using for example Vision AI to
understand very generally how users are
interacting with the different pieces of
of the content that they're exposed to
so this brings me to the use of now
image description actually yesterday on
on this stage we launched a new
component of uh our platform called
Jenna Suns it's our brand new creative
studio and essentially allows for a new
chat like interface
to help as a co-pilot content creators
to strategize campaigns starting from a
campaign brief so campaign brief
contains not only obviously text but
also images and and videos so those
images and videos are now through image
description and video description can be
synthesized obviously into into tests
and described into text allowing
therefore our
um new chatbot like which is called Leo
short for Leonardo da Vinci to then
orchestrate all the different prompts
that are then utilized within the
creative Studio to come up with the more
personalized creatives so this has
become something that was impossible for
us to do before especially manually
which now to the use of image and video
description we can now do
so this in turns allows to create much
more and much better variations of the
personalized creatives that our security
Studio comes up with so even in this
case we are able to actually utilize
vertex AIS apis in terms of image
description and video description to
better describe very granularly what
users are being exposed to and therefore
the content of each single personalized
creative
which are then extremely helpful for us
to come up with recommendation because
before we we didn't have the chance
necessarily to be able to understand
granularly why users were being exposed
to uh whereas now every single content
is better described and therefore it
allows us to really
unpack better insights which therefore
lead to recommendation and better
optimization so this creates an
extremely positive feedback loop that
starts with the studio this the then
um keeps on going with the AI
decisioning system and back to creative
intelligence
which is powered
um all uh with image description and
video description underneath even though
again you cannot necessarily see it is
not super tangible but this leads to a
much more scalable process way less
resource intensive
and therefore these essentially
summarized in Greater information then
bring better performance thank you over
to you uh Avanti thank you thank you so
much to masu that was amazing and next
We Have Bryce Perez who is uh speaking
who's a googler but he's speaking on
behalf of theta labs and they are using
some of these features to drive better
semantic search and highlight creation
so let's hear from price
thank you Avanti appreciate it wonderful
working tomorrow
well
basically I'm A Cloud engineer customer
engineer for the web 3 team and I am
honored to basically be presenting on
behalf of theta Labs so shout out to the
Theta lab CEO Mitch Leo and ctoj long
along with our team at Google Cloud web3
we have been working closely together to
bring exciting meaningful applications
for video to text AI other efforts to
described today will only scratch the
surface on things to come
today I want to talk to you about the
model pipeline video text applications
the goal is to set out to accomplish is
harnessing the computational power of
both cloud and Edge nodes
cloud is distributed Edge our
complementary complementary Computing
platforms cloud has the advantages of
offering stability uh at Cloud at scale
and high availability while the edge is
ubiquitous with with virtually unlimited
numbers of nodes these nodes mainly are
less powerful just by themselves but
when aggregated they can provide massive
parallel processing power while locating
uh more closer to the users a hybrid
Computing infrastructure could combine
the substantial benefits of Both Worlds
the Theta ads network is one of the
Leading Edge Computing platforms the
Theta Edge Network provides in
infrastructure for decentralized video
streaming and delivery the four key
advantages of data Edge Network are
scale availability resource and simple
ux
the simple ux allows a non-tech user to
Simply download the data Edge node
software and run it in the background no
active interaction is required the
provided of Rich UI experience basically
allows for job status to be shown and
allow you to earn some feedback as well
here we introduce the concept of model
pipeline running on a hybrid platform
consisting of Google cloud and data Edge
Network a model pipeline allows
conducting a tasks using multiple deep
learning models consecutively
so some of these models can be Google
proprietary models and there's
offering accessibility through Google
Cloud's API others can be open source
models that can be served by Theta Edge
Network leveraging massive parallel
processing power as mentioned as shown
in the diagram that you see the input
data versus transformed into an
intermediary representation use cloud
hosting models then the intramural data
is processed by models hosted in the
edge Network and turned into a final
output although the diagram only shows
two models the real application tasks to
utilize multiple models as shown in
later slides
now that we have introduced the concept
of the pipeline let's use a couple
applications for an example
basically we'll utilize the video
entertainment industry to illustrate its
potential the first application in
semantic video search traditionally
video search only allows searching
against title description and possibly
tags but these descriptions usually
typically provide the video uploaders
with some core quality that may not able
to capture the full details of the video
with model pipeline we can achieve much
better experience
so two images are shown it depicts the
content creator Alice uploading videos
to a video platform and after the raw
video is processed by the model pipeline
a user Bob can type in the natural
language
um into the search bar for semantic
video search
this could be allow Bob to accurately
Search interesting moments inside the
long video a massive video library is
automatically locate the replay position
inside these these typically long videos
for an example we are in the Bay Area
and by default for today we're all going
to be Golden State Warrior fans is that
agreed upon so we're going to query
Steph Curry's three-point buzzer that
was in the 2018 NBA finals this could
direct you to exact repay location of
the three-point inside the two hour long
recording of the first game of the
Warriors versus Cavaliers in 2018 NBA
finals
how can we Implement semantics video
search using model pipeline so the model
pipeline for this use case can be
consisted of three stages
the video the text capability provided
by Google cloud model video via the
vertex AI or API API Suite the vertex AI
model takes a raw video spit out a
summary of the each 15 second clips of
the video next the llm runs the the on
the in the Theta Edge Network and
collects the clip summaries
and generate tags and also a high level
of detail but the detail summary is can
be for the entire video as well the
embedding of the tags Clips summaries
and video summary are stored in the
vector database hosted by The Edge
Network finally when the user types in
search for with natural language to
embed it a query is computed in real
time which is matched against the
summary and other information found in
the vector database for the best video
in the exact repay location for that
query
so here's another exact example so we
want to be able to generate an automatic
game highlight real generation this
encompasses not just extracting exciting
moments from a video game stream or a
typical football game screen but also
generate natural language descriptions
of the Highlight clips
as shown in the figure a game streamer
uploads video and then the system
automatically transcribes the penalty
kick and the Epic goalkeeper safe
how can we implement this feature using
model pipelines similar to the video
semantic search we use case we use the
video to text model and the clip
summaries in the raw video uploaded by
the game streamer next the llm hosted by
The Edge Network perform Eclipse
sentiment analysis based on when we
assigned a score of each clip judges
whether the clip has a highlight moment
and then finally we can feed the raw
video in the beginning and end time of
the clips with top scores by offering
into a FF impex software running in the
data Edge Network and extract those
highlights and combine them into a
highlight reel
furthermore we can feed the Highlight
Reel back into the vertex AI model which
can create natural language descriptions
of the Highlight rule which could be
useful for end users and content
creators I hope that what I share with
you inspire you to build new ways to
cloud with vertex AI Bronte back to you
thanks thank you Bryce
so I think with that
we come to the end of the session I hope
you enjoyed it please spend a few
seconds giving us some feedback
so thank you all for coming and
listening today it was a real pleasure
talking to you all hope you have a great
rest of the day foreign